well here to discuss the medical aspects
of the crisis is dr. David agus he joins
us now from Los Angeles dr. agus good
morning good morning to you New York is
currently the epicenter for the cases in
the US and this week we saw the highest
single day deaths but data also showed a
slowdown in cases what phase are we at
in flattening this curve well we hope
and pray that the data reflect a trend
and they're going to continue but
they're showing is fewer
hospitalizations fewer ICU intensive
care unit admissions and fewer people
going on a ventilator on a daily basis
and so they were going up now they've
flattened the deaths had not yet
flattened but there's a delay of about a
week between hospital admissions and
decrease in death we hope that's going
to continue and it's not a a slowing of
the curve but it really is a flattening
of the curve the virus isn't isn't going
to magically disappear if the rate of
the the new cases continues to decline
how do we determine when the right time
is to ease those stay at home orders
well I mean there are two components
right there's getting the disease
incidence very low and then there's us
getting ready as a society as a country
we need testing that is who has the
virus to be in the millions per week we
are not there yet we need the ability of
testing who has been exposed and
actually has immunity so it doesn't have
to worry about catching it again or
spreading the virus that test has not
yet launched and then we need the
ability to social trace that is there
will be people who test positive and
when you do we want to go back and see
who you interacted with the days prior
because all of you need to be back
putting your homes and we will wait a
period till you can go back at again and
then we're gonna stop that virus but
there needs to be that three pronged
plan which isn't ready yet so slowing in
the cases together with technology and
our plan together then we're gonna be
able to let the dogs out if you will and
all of us go out but it will be graded
right we'll go
with masks at first higher-risk people
will stay in it's not gonna happen all
at once tragus what about treatment
we've talked we've heard about obviously
the search for a vaccine but also how to
treat the virus where are we within
those two things in terms of those two
things well there were two big things
that happened this week one is the New
England Journal of Medicine published a
study on red disappear this was the drug
intravenous drug that was developed for
Ebola that had activity against this
virus in multiple Atlanta laboratory
studies and the first human study showed
that in about 56 people about two-thirds
actually got better these were people on
a ventilator and so it didn't have a
control arm that was we don't know who
would have gotten better on their own
but the drug was well tolerated and it
appeared to have some activity in this
study the second is you know this is a
virus where you know it's not a live
organism it actually goes into our cells
and uses our own machinery to divide and
there is a drug called a protease
inhibitor that can actually block its
proteins from interacting with ours and
it was developed specifically for this
virus Pfizer has made it
and the initial laboratory data look
encouraging so those two to me are
exciting and steps for we're certainly
nowhere near we need to be with the
drugs but we are taking baby steps
forward and my hope and prayers are one
of those drugs will work because that
will dramatically change our stress
level if we can treat this disease
it sure would alright dr. David agus
thank you